A big question—if anybody’s seen the movie
'Minority Report' where people are arrested
for crimes before they actually commit them,
just because the data suggests they’re going
to commit a crime—is: are we entering this
world with so much data available?
And there definitely are clues on the internet
that people are considering committing a crime.
People really do type “how to kill your
girlfriend” on Google or “how to commit
a murder”.
So what should we do with this information
as a society?
I think we have to be really, really careful.
There’s an ethical and privacy reason to
be careful; as a society it’s not supposed
to be illegal to have bad thoughts.
But I think there’s also a data science
reason for this.
One of the things that you do see in this
data is that a lot of people have horrific
thoughts or make horrific searches without
ever going through with a horrific action.
So it may be that when we have all this data
we think we’re just going to be able to
figure out exactly who is a risk of committing
a crime or doing something bad, but it may
be that it’s just really, really hard because
a huge percentage of people look really, really
bad on paper but never go through with the
action.
There is a study of Prosper, a peer-to-peer
lending firm.
So people can apply for loans, and scholars
analyzed what people wrote in their loan application,
and whether they paid back their loan.
And they found that you could predict whether
someone will pay back the loan based on the
words that person used in their loan application.
So if a person uses the phrase “I promise”
they’re much less likely to pay back a loan,
because I guess everybody lies, so “I promise”
is a clue that you’re not going to pay back
the loan.
And one of the more striking indicators, one
of the single highest indicators you’re
not going to pay back the loan, is if you
use the word “God” in your loan application.
And this is kind of a little bit eerie and
suggests a potentially dark future.
It means that someone, a lender, would be
“wise” to not give a loan to anybody who
mentions God.
If someone says, “God bless you” in a
loan application they’re put together in
a large group of other people who tend, on
average, not to pay back their loans.
So there’s real danger to some of this big
data where a lot of the correlation—everything
kind of correlates with everything else, and
sometimes for reasons that we don’t understand,
some words people use, or likes they have
on Facebook, predict that they’re going
to do bad things, even if they’re not really
going to do bad things, and they may be punished
without even realizing why.
One thing you see in the Google search data
related to religion is the questions people
have, and they’re usually concentrated in
the Bible Belt.
But people have kind of loaded questions about
God.
So “why does God allow bad things to happen
to good people?” or “why does God allow
suffering?” or “why does God need so much
praise?”
These are questions that people might not
raise aloud because they don’t want to share
their doubts with others, but they turn to
Google and ask some really, really loaded
questions about some of the stories that they
hear related to religion.